we are seeing on UC campuses violence
and a failure to respond to the violence
we are
seeing and when there's a gap like that
between an incident the targeted group
of students that's a Ed and whether or
not the university is enforcing policy
in place when they're not enforcing it
that to me is
discrimination my concern as a Jewish
student is that the UC Board of Regents
the chancellors and administration at
large I don't know if they understand
why Jewish students on UC campuses are
not okay right now so we've seen
acknowledgement from the University
leadership saying we hear you and we see
you but why students are not okay this
is not about First Amendment rights
first uh Free Speech nor is it about
stifling speech this is about the fact
that when there are issues and incidents
affecting Jewish students on campus I am
not seeing the university enforce the
policies in place so we've had two
Jewish students physically assaulted on
campus
when expressing their Jewish identity
via holding an Israeli flag to convey
their national origin which as you may
know is a protected trait under title 6
so right now the university in
ucpd they've not declared those hate
crimes more importantly though they're
not even investigating those crimes as
hate crimes so that is problematic
because as a Jewish woman I interpret
that as if I express my Jewish Identity
On Campus as it relates to my connection
to the Jewish homeland the Jewish state
of Israel if I am physically assaulted
or attacked the university will not even
investigate that as a hate crime and
that tells me I'm not safe to fully
express my Jewish Identity On
Campus what matters is that Jewish
students were
intimidated and they were aggressively
approached and their personal property
was attempted to be taken and they were
verbally harassed because of an item
they were carrying to convey and express
their Jewish identity so whether it was
a t-shirt they're wearing to express
their identity and they're attacked a
backpack whether it's another object
that they're holding what matters is
that they were doing something to
protect to express a protected
characteristic of theirs their Jewish
identity
and that would qualify I believe as a
hate crime because they were targeted
based on a protected
characteristic however the university is
not investigating it as a hate
crime the university they could not
prevent that from happening and I as
Hannah am not asking them to prevent
that from happening what I'm asking is
that when crimes like these occur that
affect Jewish students I ask that they
follow the policy in place and for both
of these cases Jewish students have
filed police reports with
ucpd in both of those two cases my
understanding is that the university is
not investigating those as hate crimes
so again it's one thing to declare it a
hate crime it's another not to even
investigate it as such and I'm an MBA
I'm not a lawyer I have though quite
extensively read different policies to
understand when this happens what is the
University supposed to do how are they
supposed to respond and it appears that
the information and facts provided to
these two Jewish students is not
consistent with what I'm reading and
it's because of that
inconsistency that I feel confident
saying I'm wondering if there's
discrimination at Berkeley against Jews
and I want to do something about
it